all right johnny what are we talking
about today here we go
we're going to talk about a little bit
you know i talk a lot in my interviews i
talk a lot about being down here in los
angeles you know me running around the
hood
running around here in downtown l.a you
know different parts of la but
i've never shared you know uh when i
went out of state you know i mean when i
was about 15 years old this must have
been oh man
i say 87 88
maybe i was about 15 years old and it
was getting hot down here you know
the texas kept coming to the house you
know what i mean you know
he kept right in the house for my uncle
and kept right now for my brother you
know so it was becoming too hot at the
house you know
every time they raided it they'll just
take me to jail let me out in a few
hours but
i didn't like the feeling so you know i
got my grandma i told her you know
i want to go to uh to mexico you know
she said i already sent you over there
you know me i already went over i wanted
to go back but she didn't want to send
me
so she said well i want to stay in
arizona for a little while you know with
some people up there and i was like all
right let's check it out you know what i
mean let's go you know
it was the summer was gone so i was
figuring it's not that hot
still i got there and it was [ __ ]
boiling hot and we're in the middle of
october
like right now it was boiling hot you
know i i got there and um
you know the school year was passing and
i wanted to get enrolled in school
because i just didn't want to run around
there have the cops or the children
catch me because remember i went there
by myself
lo and behold i what i did was i got
some money together i got my clothes
together and i went to
to the bus depot not this one the old
bus depot the one that i used to be on
seventh and maple um yeah right there on
saturday maple the old black people so i
went over there
you know i remember when i got there you
know some food snatched my luggage real
fast man
i thought he was trying to steal my [ __ ]
so i gave chase to him and he's like hey
i'm just helping you out you know i
didn't know that those dudes would help
you take your luggage you know wherever
it gots to go and you know break them
off whatever change your dollars
i thought he was robbing me you know i'm
young i'm 15. he's grabbing my suitcases
he's grown man
i'm like man i get out of here anyways i
gave him some change i get on the bus
so on the way on the way to arizona
we're like halfway there
and all of a sudden the bus pulls over
into the side of the road
and then i see sirens you know flashing
in the windows and i'm like oh [ __ ]
they pulled over the [ __ ] bus oh man
i hope they didn't [ __ ] see me or
you know they're looking for me so i'm
thinking it's all about me nah he got on
the bus and took this man and this
little kid off
and took them both you know so it was
cool but i was already busting
out my my pictures that i took you know
i mean in la and stuff just in case you
know
because i don't got no id you know what
i mean and a lot of times right there
in that part of the trip to arizona
they deport people you know that's by
coachella india all that area
they deported out of people you know
what i mean they catch you on the bus by
yourself no idea nothing no one with you
of course they're gonna take you you
know meanwhile they bypassed me
cool i went all the way to arizona when
i got there i got there it was about it
was late at night
so i went you know what i mean when the
backyard kicked it they got
like spot out there kicked him back your
way till the next day next day came i
was like okay
what am i gonna do over here you know i
couldn't sell drugs you know what i mean
at my grandma's house i can just run
wild right here or
i could enroll in school and see what
that's like you know i'm only 15
so i got one of my aunts and i'm like
can you enroll me in school she didn't
want to do it so my cousin
she ended up doing it they enrolled me
in school put my grandmother's address
now i'm going to school right i'm going
to school up there and you know
it's it's it's similar to back home but
it's just a lot slower you know i mean
they ain't
doing as much [ __ ] they're doing it on
the low but they're not doing as much
[ __ ] as we're doing
back in la you know they're about three
years back you know
but uh one time i'm kicking it you know
what i mean and i was watching this dude
you know he was
mexican and puerto rican he lived across
the street from me
and um oh we should see him leaving that
night coming back at night you know i'm
wondering what the [ __ ] is this dude up
to you know so
one time he walks by i call him when we
smoke a cigarette we get to know each
other
lonely i know this dude's a a robber you
know he he robs all kinds of [ __ ] you
know i mean
i'm down there with him and i'm saying
[ __ ] it let's go let's just go for a
world you know see what's up
he goes well i'll be back right now i
got to go get something so he leaves he
comes back
when he comes back he has this this this
i i got to be that here
a four truck big one keem cab
a long bed i'm talking about high-ass
truck and
bad [ __ ] four-wheel drive
everything right it looks brand new
so i'm like where'd you get this truck
out he's like man i just went to the car
lot
got inside the office man opened the
[ __ ] all the keys were hanging i grabbed
the key got in it and took off i'm like
yeah but there's poles and chains
he goes nah man he goes i'll show you he
took me over there in a trip because all
those parts all those
used car lots always have one pole that
comes up
and then you can lay it on the ground
and that lays the chain out you know i
never knew that i never knew that too he
showed me
so we went over there but we took the
pole out laid it down we went inside the
office he went inside pull all the keys
out we're
looking at the kids and boom i see this
nice ass uh
a trans am i'm like i'm gonna take the
trans am it's blocked in so i'm like
okay you got to move the white truck you
know and what it is is
it's just a you know a set like this a
set which is a gang of keys in there
and they all have what year what color
what model so you need to just look at
the car lot get the key in boom press
door you know you got the car so
we ended up getting about three or four
that night now we're cruising around
we're wondering where are we going to
take them we're going to take them so i
said well you know what
we could wait till the morning and then
we could drive to mexico i mean and next
was only 13 miles
so i figured the worst that could happen
is we got to walk back
i mean that's the worst that could
happen so we go there's about
five of us we go in about three cars we
go a truck and two cars we go
there we meet some dude we met on this
side over here
he's talking about his hands and
everything live right there and he they
did
and they want to buy all the cars as
soon as we get there
so we got there and we stayed a little
while we went and party would do we went
deeper in
into mexico we went through um the
border of called algodones
it's um in between san luis
mexico and chicago like that yeah make
aliyah one of those it's right in the
middle it's
little ass border got like one car goes
in one car goes out
small ass border by the canyon you got
to drive along the colorado to get there
you mean it's it's a small ass border so
we get there
and we roll through like nothing boom we
roll through and first when we get there
dudes like one let's go to the bar you
know and i didn't know that you know you
can be any age
to drink in mexico you just gotta act
right you know i mean if you act the
food you can take you to jail you're
[ __ ]
but if you act right you know you could
have women sitting on your lap
i had a woman sitting on my lap i was
15. you know me and i was buying rounds
buying rounds because you know over
there
like 20 bucks man i'll buy you like
[ __ ] like seven rounds in the bar you
know with everybody there
so we're buying [ __ ] we're buying [ __ ]
my uncle walks in
boom my grandfather's brother i'm
thinking oh [ __ ] man
i'm throwing one guess who's gonna tell
no
he said what's up how you doing man
grabbing yourself two broads set them on
his lap
and started partying and i was like okay
this way ain't gonna tell me
so we went over there and we have okay
the dude told us that we're gonna get
2500 truck and two thousand a car
nah you know when you get somewhere
everybody always in the deal when you
get somewhere a [ __ ] wants to
change it up
we're in mexico what could we say you
know i mean he's trying to shortchange
us like 2 000 but what can we say we're
in mexico
you know what i mean once over here we
got no backing you know i'm all the way
in la
where we're at in arizona next 30 miles
away so i'm like damn this food's gonna
get us [ __ ] it
we told them yeah yeah whatever so we
got it we put them in our pockets now
remember we're there all day
what happened was we lost track of time
the border closes at eight o'clock
exactly
it's like ten till eight so we're like
[ __ ]
we got no chance to get in the car
nothing we gotta run so we run man we
run
we get there it's like five minutes to
close we get there we go through boom
boom with our money now we're stuck and
we got 13 miles to walk
along the colorado 30 miles is a long
time when you ain't got no water
it's a [ __ ] far-ass height believe me
i did it
and we did it because we had no ride
nothing um
a little ways there this old man in his
rv and his wife
pulled over to the side gave us some
water and told us we'd hang on it
hang on his rv and get a ride to the rv
place and that's like halfway
so we drain water whatever we get on his
rv and we're all hanging on and he gives
us a ride all the way over there
so we're halfway through our trip we're
like maybe eight miles into it and i
mean
this is sick and it's told man my legs
are burning you know what i mean
constantly thirsty you know and it's
[ __ ] hot over there you know what i
mean but
when you're in arizona and you're there
for a while you become accustomed to the
heat
like anywhere else you know what i mean
but the heat is so hot where you man
i used to see my little cousins walking
barefooted on a cement and it's like 115
degrees
you know what i mean i used to be like
man they their feet must be [ __ ] hard
or something because it's really hot out
here and they're walking like nothing
but being that they live there all their
life i guess they came accustomed to
that heat
you know i tried to put my foot down on
the cement hell no you could fry egg on
that [ __ ] cement you know and they're
walking
all the way to the market barefooted you
know and that's pavement sidewalk rocks
everything
it ain't phasing them you know so you
know when i was in arizona
we kind of got used to the heat so that
was that was that was a little up from
us walking
but we're about maybe a quarter of a
mile still a quarter of a way to go
still
and i'm thinking that we ain't going to
make it man this is too [ __ ] hot man
here comes one of the fellas man he came
from the school he went to the border
scene was closed came back around seen
us walking
went all the way down turned around came
in and picked us up you know what i'm
saying he picked us up dude was only 13
years old you know what i'm saying
i gave him his props he was only 13. he
came for us you know no one asked him
no one told him [ __ ] you know i mean he
hustled our conversation that's how he
found out where we're going
he wanted to go he went and got a car
and everything so he could go and he's
only 13.
but when he came with the car you know
where we leave we're like man [ __ ] we
just gave him you know me a couple
hundred dollars each you know because he
came to pick us up
in the middle of nowhere you know so we
get back over there
and and you know you got over there in
arizona you can understand that that
they're not
as quick as us they're not so adapt to
cars getting stolen you know saying that
something happens big
comes out in the paper everybody's
talking about it now there's cars coming
up missing from those car lots like
four or five every other night we're
taking them we're just taking them you
know taking them no there's
oh [ __ ] over there there must be 20 30
car lots you know i mean and they're all
the same it's all the same build they're
built all the same way you know i don't
understand that's not really a
burglary proof you know but being that
we're over there and it's a lot slower
maybe they're not too hip to locking
that [ __ ] behind something where you
can't get in you know what i mean
and they didn't do it so everywhere we
went and where we went i went like they
opened the front door i looked in boom
whole set of keys man everywhere we went
you know we did that we did that and
you know the reason i bring it is
because you know i was on a whole
different page with those dudes there
was no gang
gang gang banging involved i didn't have
no enemies over there i mean there was
dudes from hoods over there
you know and they were from l.a hoods
but they moved arizona and they started
came in arizona
you know those jews didn't say [ __ ] it
was more the dudes that came from alley
and went over there and
like you know transplanted over there
and now they feel like they're running
something you know so we got [ __ ] with
them a couple of times
you know in front of the school down in
their hood you know but other than that
it was cool
you know i didn't have to worry about
walking down the street over there and
getting shot in the back you know i mean
i gotta look over my shoulder you know
right there you can drink beer you know
what i mean the cops don't really sweat
[ __ ] you know i mean like the sweatshirt
in l.a you know
you know i was really comfortable over
there you know i was thinking man i
might just stay here you know me and get
a girlfriend you know what i mean
you know raise a family and just kick it
but no
it ain't happening you know it ain't
happening about [ __ ] three weeks into my
stay
phone call comes from the hood you know
i mean hey you got to come back you know
what i mean
my little brother got out he's running a
muck you know i mean and i don't want
him out there by himself
so i'm like damn how am i going to get
back home you know what i mean i'm
getting back home
i'm thinking the ground that's too
[ __ ] long man that [ __ ] is too long
you know now i had some money on me from
the cars you know so
i got one of the neighbors a white boy
right there and i was like hey man let's
go to l.a you know i'll take you over
there with me we'll kick it you know
what i mean
you know a lot of my family will go and
post up he's like man it's a good idea
let's do it
so [ __ ] we loaded his car we got his
car and we drove all the way halfway
there
this [ __ ] broke down in the middle of
nowhere i'm talking about
just [ __ ] mountains and [ __ ]
bushes nothing you know i mean nothing
nobody's stopping nobody's stopping all
of a sudden here comes the highway
patrol
therefore stopped helped us we fixed the
car and we got on you know
out of everybody he stopped the highway
patrol nobody else was stopping man
[ __ ] were flying by
you know you know i'm trying to tell
them wait you know [ __ ] i was out
nobody nobody you know it's [ __ ] hot
we're in the middle of the [ __ ]
desert
we're like about 10 miles from glamis
that's the [ __ ] sand dunes
you know over there in that area you
know it's the sand dunes and we're
[ __ ] just
we're stranded man well he helps us out
we get to a
gas station we call some heads they they
come and get us but we're you know we're
halfway there
and uh you know when they came and got
us you know we we had some stuff we
brought from over there because you know
in arizona you know you can do
certain things you can't do in
california you know you can acquire
certain things you can't acquire in
california you could acquire in arizona
it's different law you know
i seen an old man walking to the store
and he had two coal 45 pistols
on his lap you know with a gang of
bullets like that you know and he was
maybe like
he had to be at least 70 80. you know
what i mean he had his two guns right
there
and he was walking down the street like
nothing and i was like how the [ __ ]
could he walk down you know
with his guns like that he's like no
ain't no cop it's kind of old to be a
cop
so i asked the man at the store i'm like
how's that guy just come in here with
guns he's like
arizona law you can branch firearms on
your hips you know you can have a farm
on your hip as long as it's visible and
you know you're showing it
you can have that i didn't know that you
know and then little by little i started
seeing more
people strapped up strapped i seen this
dude had a [ __ ] belt buckle like this
and they had a little ass gun with like
four bullets in it and it was his belt
buckle
and shot 22's little ass little ass gun
on his powerbook you just push a button
that should fall right in your hand
i seen that one that was right after i
seen that man with the with the core 45s
because
now it's interesting you know i mean
damn over in arizona you can just buy
them over the counter like
[ __ ] we ain't getting close over there
so i do my thing you know and
they handle their business like i was
saying we got halfway there and that's
what we're really concerned about
when the hand patrol came we weren't
really tripping because he's by himself
and he was gonna look to the car
he had to look really good where hiding
place was at you know because we made a
hiding place work
it's even hard for us to [ __ ] find it
you know what i mean so we made you know
we got we get back to la
and as soon as we get back back to l.a
my little brother he's in jail
i wasn't in jail for oh he got busted
for a shooting last night
i said i told him i called i was coming
the next day but he couldn't wait
you know he was fresh out of jail you
know what i mean when you're fresh out
of jail you know you got all that
animosity built up
all those [ __ ] rumors you hear about
your girlfriend you don't mean about
your homies
so you want to get out there and smash
everybody you know me but
i honestly tell you there's not enough
time
to smash everybody you know i mean
everybody ain't worth it you know not
all gas weapons are good you know
you might whip a fool's ass and you know
he's going to call the cops you know
that that's
that's what i'm really concerned about
these days that you know
over there when i was in arizona you
know they called the cops to me for
beating up a dude and they just came
broke us up and left over here i got a
bus rubin of a dude
they arrested me when i gave him a song
battery and both of us were bleeding
but being that he called you know i mean
he called him on me he said i should
have called but
i'm not a cop caller you know saying i
couldn't i can't do that you know
it's really hard for me to call any law
enforcement because the fact that i just
don't agree with a lot of their tactics
you know the things they do you know
what i'm saying i don't agree with them
you know what i mean and
right now they're off the chain so i
don't call them for nothing you know i
mean i like to get my camera and watch
them
because they're always doing some dumb
[ __ ] you know what i mean they're always
doing some dumb ass [ __ ]
but um over there in arizona you know
right before i left
i got a can of paint and i started
sniffing paint and when i was sniffing
paint
i thought my cousin was trying to set me
up so i ended up beating her up
cops came arrest me take me to jail put
me in juvenile hall
and the one thing i remember about that
junior hall is when you get there they
got this thing called adjustment
for a whole day you have to sit in your
room with your mattress rolled up
with water food wherever but you can't
lay down for a whole day this
and this is in arizona juvenile hall you
know they they only sit down for a whole
[ __ ] day
and i didn't understand that you know
that's like inhumane you know you could
use the bathroom you know but you had to
stay sitting there you couldn't lay down
close your eyes you know they'd bend
your door you know what i mean i was
like how the [ __ ] does that work you
know
adjustment for a child you know i mean
so you know arizona has its goods and
its bads you know
it's arizona like you do something you
rob a liquor store they give you like 27
years man
but you only be doing like six seven but
they give you this way out number like
56 years
do you see dude out in like five years
you know what i mean their dogs are
different than us you know i mean
they run their [ __ ] different you know
they're everything
their ideas look different they're
[ __ ] everything is is
it's like more like a western [ __ ] that
i noticed they got more like a different
heritage back then you know
behind them you know i used to go oh we
always did school
i remember when i was in high school we
used to ditch school like 15 of us
and we'd go to the colorado river it was
like three blocks away from the high
school
so we'll go on we'll take plastic bags
and when the true officers and the cops
will come
we'll just jump in the water and scream
to the other side and get out over there
and [ __ ] you you know they they can't
come on that side it's not the
jurisdiction
that's california you know and so we go
back and forth you know what i mean and
[ __ ] with the cops you know the only
ones we didn't really [ __ ] with was the
the [ __ ] border patrol because those
foods don't give a [ __ ] they're going
anywhere on any side you know in the
water and they'll come and get you they
have believe me
so we were doing that for a while we're
ditching and because we're ditching
more and more people were finding out so
like at the
ditchy party we had there we must be had
like 50 60 people there
and the cops came and raided true
officers everything a lot of people got
in
got in trouble and the whole thing you
know what i hated about this situation
is
when they all got in trouble all their
fingers went to me you know they all
pointed to me
you know and i kind of figured it
because they weren't doing nothing like
that over there they weren't
still you know cars they weren't [ __ ]
jumpy people they weren't doing that
they
they were just going to school their
[ __ ] thing was to go to the arcade or
you know go [ __ ] playing an abandoned
building you know
they didn't know nothing about let's go
take some cars drive them over here and
you get thousands in your pockets
so a lot of those dudes that i did that
with you know a lot of them now are in
jail
you know i talked to a couple of them
you know i mean they're still doing
their thing but
i kind of feel bad cause you know i kind
of started them off on that
bad trail you know what i mean but i let
them know you didn't gotta call me i'll
go myself i'll just come pick you
after with the girls but no they want to
go they want to take their own car they
want to look cool okay
go ahead you know so a few of them i
know went to jail behind that
behind fingerprints because remember i
just got there so they didn't have me
down on file
those foods though they went to jail
cops came to their house
raided their [ __ ] took all their dad's
guns stuck their guns [ __ ] took
everything you know what i mean and
took them to jail you know and what was
crazy was
they got booked for other [ __ ] that i
knew nothing about
and it was supposed to be all of us
together so these fools were putting
some slick [ __ ]
and they got caught up because they
pulled slick [ __ ] you know but
you know i wanted to show you today
about you know i'm always talking about
here in l.a you know
but it's anywhere you go you know
anywhere you go if you're part of a
certain environment you're going to find
where those people are you know if you
want to get high you're going to look so
long
that you're going to eventually see
someone that's doing the
the movement or something of someone
who's high so many places i've been when
i got to arizona first dude i asked
oh yeah he would get everything you know
what i mean you know i've had that
happen to me a lot here in l.a you know
big truck drivers and [ __ ] would pull
over and come and get at me and be like
hey man can you hook me up i'm always
from kentucky
i'm just coming through this is a stop
you know
and i'm thinking man i want to hook this
fool up but damn once he says hey man
i'll give you 200
for yourself like what the [ __ ] just for
picking up for him you're gonna give me
200 bucks
and that's not just what he's giving
he's only giving me that from the
beginning this is not when i bring him
back to [ __ ] and he sees this a lot he's
happy now
she breaks me off another 40. you know
and then before i leave another 40.
so you know before breaks me off 3 400
500 and
it's happened like maybe seven eight
times right here in los angeles and i'm
just walking down the street
been approached by women a man men and
women and they're all truck drivers you
know me and i'm wondering
why would they ask me you know
what what what aura or what do i give
off
saying that i would know where to find
drugs you know even
i'm all just walking down the street i
mean i know they can't see that i'm high
on drugs
they can't but i mean it's just so bad
that you know
people from another state cruising
through
stopped me to buy them drugs you know
and i'm like
okay what do i got to change i got to
change my attire
do i got to change my appearance more
you know i'm almost 50 years old and i'm
tired of youngsters
mad dog and me asking me where i'm from
you know what i mean it's like
22 year old 21 year old kid asking where
i'm from i'm almost 50 years old
so a lot of times i just want to bend
them over and spank them
but then again i knew i was like that
before you know i was at that
at that age you know but i want to share
that with you this time you know about
it don't matter where you go man it's
not just here in los angeles
and skid row it's everywhere you know
i've been
from one tip of california always to the
other side and every [ __ ] city
has a ghetto a slum the hood you know
i've been places where they got
actually got rolls and rolls what they
call slam shacks
they're abandoned houses up on stilts
and all the people go in there and slam
and they're living there
you know there's no landlord there's no
nothing and it's just rolls and rolls of
empty houses
and it's a trip because i know when i
first went in there it's a regular house
but it's called a slam shack and they
got like 15 on this side
10 on that side five on that side i've
never ever seen it their only place i've
ever seen it was madeira california
in madeira california they have what
they call slam shacks and they're crazy
because
everything's in there syringes all kinds
of [ __ ] everywhere you know and
the cops never go in there you know what
i mean and i was like whoa you know so
every place has a place where you can
find
trouble that's what i'm saying you know
and if you're gonna find your own
trouble finding you trouble always finds
me wherever i go
i end up leaving arizona because i had
any cops already on our tail and [ __ ]
they're already booking all these fools
so i up in adam's got on came back here
to alley but i just wanted to share that
with you mark you know
i have some good stuff next time you
know some better [ __ ]
you